aujourd'hui on va parler d'une image
d'une installation choisi par olivier
christain et grâce à son travail
on va comprendre comment elle nous aide
à remettre en question la représentation
de la démocratie
[Musique]
des gradins est un immense miroir de
même dimension
disposant vis-à-vis sans perchoir sans
pupitre 100 points vers lequel devrait
converger tous les regards ce projet
d'installation de l'artiste nicolas
milhé en partie réalisées en 2010 est
dans la cour d'honneur de l'université
de lyon bouleverse le langage les codes
et les usages symbolique de la politique
cette oeuvre c'est une agora un lieu
d'échangés entre les citoyens
symbole de la démocratie et cette agora
elle est presque vide uniquement occupé
par un chien isolé qui permet de
visualiser les proportions de l'oeuvre
et le vide de l'espace où devraient se
regrouper des dizaines de personnes
nicolas milhé sous la piscine question
centrale des systèmes démocratiques
celles de la représentation une question
que le discours et la pratique politique
courante oubli ou ignorent délibérément
cette installation c'est en effet une
architecture moral elle montre la
représentation nationale dans la vie
politique
sauf qu'elle est différent d
architecture politique auquel nous
sommes habitués comme l'hémicycle par
exemple qui est la disposition la plus
commune dans le régime représentatif la
disposition particulière de l'agora elle
nous surprend et nous amène à réfléchir
sur l'avenir des pratiques démocratiques
comme le souligne olivier christain nous
en faisons tous partie et nous devrions
constamment nous demander ce qu'est cet
espace politique et le rôle de ce qu'il
occupe avec nous ou pour nous nous
devons nous demander ce qu'est une
assemblée politique est ce que l'
architecture des lieux où elle se réunit
peut dire de son fonctionnement
l'agora en miroir nous invite à nous
demander ce que constitue réellement une
représentation politique juste ou
démocratique celle doit forcément nous
ressemble et être à l'image d'une
société ou si elle peut se reposer sur
des professionnels qui nous représente
autrement siège pour nous et décide en
notre nom
elle soulève des questions essentielles
en démocratie comme la critique
contemporaine des élections la
dénonciation des impasses du régime
représentatif classique encore la
réévaluation de la pertinence du tirage
au sort des citoyens pour remplacer
l'aristocratie des élus l'installation
de nicolas milhé nous fait donc
retrouver la forme politique de la
démocratie directe dans laquelle les
citoyens prennent directement par dans
l'agora aux décisions qui les concernent
et de cette façon elle nous fait
considérer à nouveau notre présence dans
la cité comme l'une de nos obligations
ipa faut donc s'asseoir sur les gradins
de l'agora moderne de nicolas millet et
nous voir siéger nous mêmes dans ce lieu
de débat public et politique pour
comprendre la puissance de son travail
et l'urgence démocratique qui les révèle
merci à lui et christain qui nous a
permis de faire cette vidéo et à bientôt
sur une image une histoire
[Musique]